now nevada's higher education board of
regents are discussing a covet 19
vaccine mandate for staff but before a
decision comes the public is getting a
chance to speak out as well bianca
holman is live for us this afternoon to
track the meeting joining us live in the
newsroom with the latest bianca hey good
afternoon john so public comments
started shortly after nine this morning
and it lasted until about 11 30. there's
been passionate comments on both sides
the nevada system of higher education
covers eight campuses the policy would
require all 23 thousand plus employees
to be fully vaccinated by december 1st
or risk getting fired but not everyone
agrees with the mandate i have gone out
of my way to
teach well because i really love it
but now i i'm
i'm i'm i'm here you know
uh having to maybe quit my job because
uh because i i don't want to put on the
vaccine name i do have reasons
my god i have a condition and my primary
doctor told me not to take it so i'm
here for my life about a fifth of nshe
employees are unvaccinated as of
september 20th medical and religious
exemptions would be considered despite
what others have said the science in the
situation is clear vaccines are very
safe and highly effective
combating covet 19 and vaccine mandates
are the last
remaining powerful tool in our arsenal
to help end this pandemic
now once there is is a decision we will
keep you updated online and on air
biancolman live local now
bianca thank you very much